hey at seven I recently did a webinar on
social media with the guys from digital
vidya and we had so many questions at
the end of it that I couldn't get to the
mall and I promised everybody that I had
asked a question that I would do a video
response for those who I couldn't answer
on the on the webinar itself and so I
finally got the Excel spreadsheet of all
the questions and hopefully I'm not
shooting myself in the foot here with
all the questions here but I'm gonna
answer the questions and let's see how
it go so the topic is social media so
let's see what we got what we got what
we got him can we choose one single word
for business any tips yes so the main
theme of the the webinar was picking one
word to define your business when you do
that you you stand for something
important you attract people who want to
work with you you're sharing stuff in
your social media campaigns that mean
something that get people excited that
people want to then spread right most
yourself is boring and it is having one
word that means something to you and
when you're creating content for it it's
it's your guiding beacon such as social
media is everything every decision you
have to make in your business you can
match it up to your one word so another
example again me and believe i got the
plane i believe is on the back you have
to believe in entrepreneurs to be a part
of my team right if you look at the
content that i share on social media all
of them facebook twitter youtube it's
always about believing in entrepreneurs
is giving helpful advice tips
suggestions and if if something comes
across my desk that I like that even if
I have in Korea I just like it I'll
share it because it relates to believe
and everybody who follows me on other
social media networks are used to that
kind of content so they love it how do
you pick your one word assuming you're
the owner of the business the one word
isn't about your business it's about you
it's finding your own personal one word
and the way to find it so I'm writing an
entire book on this but let me try to
condense it into like a couple minutes
think about all the things that make you
happy in your life and have always made
you happy thinking about your favorite
book your best friend your favorite
movie the music you like to listen to
the company's you've started your
favorite boss what you love about your
parents there's a common theme across
everything that makes you happy there's
one word that connects all of them and
that's what you want to build your one
word campaign around and it's a personal
one word that you bring to your business
so believers mine I you know my favorite
movie is Seabiscuit it's about this
horse that everybody counted out and
came back and won all these races it was
one of nobody believed in but they
believe in themselves and so I brought
that to my business another example a
buddy of mine runs a training company
called last minute training and he is
really he loves customer service so what
he wants to do is delight people and he
believes in that himself it's this is a
value right it's a core value to you
it's not your it's not just your
business and whatever you bring comes to
your business so he sells training but
his core value was delighted so his work
is about being delighted and that's what
he he focuses his business on if you
come you're hiring sales movers company
if you don't believe in hiring if you
don't believe in delighting the customer
you're not going to have a great job
you're not going to fit in with that
business he's not going to hire you even
if you look great on paper social media
stuff these planning should be around
being delight and delight in your
customers and so it's a guiding beacon
it so it's finding your own personal one
word at your own personal value the most
important value to you and then bringing
that to your business and everything
that you do that was from sue rob thank
you for the question the next one comes
from and I'm you know I'm sorry if I
mispronounced your guys names indrajit
who wrote in how such how can one word
be patented is it essential so you can't
patent the word you can't patent the
word it's not going to happen and ideal
you're picking a word that is if you're
picking a word with power that has
meaning somebody else has used it before
if you look at believe you know for me
that means something to me but tons of
people have used belief before right you
know Justin Bieber has a
album called believe there's lots of
songs that have that have been used that
called believe and that's ok that's
great like these are all there they're
aligned with me to these are all
potential partners for me to work with
so don't worry about patenting your one
word you can't it's your value you
should want to spread it and share it
and let people know what it means to you
why it's important because you're going
to track people who believe in the same
thing you have that same one word that's
the ideal way ok next if I'm new to
social media marketing what would you
recommend the test the waters while
managing online reputation this is from
Sri Ram so if you're new to social media
starts slowly because too many people
they start social media they they go
crazy they post you know five times a
day and then they give up after two
weeks because they're not see any
results you have to make sure that
you're getting results from it and so on
the webinar and you can go back to watch
it again and maybe this question was
asked early i talked about how to take
baby steps and get started on a small
scale prove it so first step is just
make sure you have the accounts nobody
else can take it from you then research
to see if your customers are actually
there right if your customers are on
twitter you should be on twitter its
marketing 101 you want to be where your
customers are if your customers aren't
on twitter don't go on twitter it's not
worth your time because your customers
aren't there so be where your customers
are number three is just just pay
attention pay attention and see people
are talking about you right even if you
just have your twitter name on your web
site of a customer's looking for you
they may talk about you right i'd like
to look for the twitter handle of the
companies that i deal with and i'll talk
about them so just saying just just see
people are talking about you then
recognize your champions so the people
who are talking about you you just say
thank you right you're not actively
doing anything none of this actually
takes much time at all all of that is
pretty simple easy you're not going to
get bombarded with questions and then
slowly work into creating content ok you
post your thoughts your expertise things
that mean something to you again think
about things around your one word start
with just something once a week don't go
crazy show results prove to your
hope that it's worth your time right
you're busy entrepreneur I'm a busy
entrepreneur you're busy in your job
whatever you're doing you don't have
time to spend five hours a day on social
media right you have to prove that it's
worth the time investment so prove it to
yourself prove that people are
interacting with you share only things
that mean something to you once a week
start it off and show that people are
interacting or responding to you love
your stuff and then slowly start
expanding but every step along the way
you're proving to yourself that this
thing works okay next for smbs the
social media marketing budget is that
much how do you reach more audiences
organically thanks a lot for the amazing
session it's perfect that's from a meet
so I'm glad you enjoyed it and me I
don't believe we need to do advertising
in a social media campaign the key is
that again you're making somebody feel
something because if you poor
advertising dollars on top of a mediocre
campaign a crappy campaign if you're out
there just promoting your coupon codes
and hey here check out my latest blog
post advertising that is not going to
help you with anything you're not gonna
you don't need a budget right yeah but
unlimited budgets not going to help you
because it's not something that people
want to read right doesn't have any
feeling to it on the other side you'll
see tons of campaigns that have get
started that have no advertising budget
but have feeling to it say something
strong stand for something and people
just want to share it right if you look
at you look at myself I don't advertise
any of my stuff there's no advertising
dollars spent you look at the belief
video that I talked about in the my
youth in the webinar no other times I
also spent on that 350,000 views on it
because it's a the message is something
that connects with people so what I
would say is if you give a limited
budget dollar-wise you have a limited
amount of time whatever your spending
should go into creating something
amazing don't worry about the marketing
promoting of it because if it's good
people will share it that's the power of
social media so spend your dollars your
time your energy your resources on
creating something that when you look at
it you say yeah that's awesome I made
that you should feel proud of
whatever you're creating and don't worry
about posting something three times a
week post something once a week make it
great make an amazing feel proud you
know you want to make something that
you're happy to show your family
something you're happy to show your
parents are your kids or your co-workers
or your friends right like look what I
just me it's got to be that strong if
it's that strong and people feel the
same connection then they're going to
want to share with their friends you
don't need advertising dollars 40 k next
but Baba so this is from soo Rob maybe
another scrub I'm a student and
launching a new website next week I want
to create buzz any suggestions from you
for social media buzz so for a new
website launch I'd say again think about
what what you want to accomplish with
the site right why are you creating this
site what big problem are you trying to
solve because her website there's tons
of websites millions of websites people
onto websites all the time and i get i
get hit up constantly with people wanted
me to promote their website what big
problem does your website saw but why
should I care right if I had to
underline one main theme for all of my
talks and everything it's that you want
people to care if people care they'll
share it if they don't care they won't
and no matter how much you span people
and bombard people and plastic people
with messages if they don't care about
it they're not going to share so what
big message does your website have what
big problem are you solving and how can
you get people to care if you can do
that then people will spread it and I
would think about so maybe a more
tactical thing if I could think about
who to reach out to find people who are
aligned with your mission so if you had
a new website for entrepreneurs that
solved a really big problem for
entrepreneurs you'd want to share it
with me where you can reach out to me on
Twitter and people do all the time and
let me know about this new website
you're launching right find people who
have a community that is a strong
community of your target audience I
reach out to them and let them know what
you're doing but again it's got to be
something good right if you send me a
link to your new website and it sucks or
it's just self-promotional and I don't
see the valued entrepreneurs then I'm
not going to go be happy with it right
I'm not going to
pay attention on the next thing you send
me so make sure that your website is
really strong and that people care about
it next from Prashant if your company
has three products each represented one
word how do you market them separately
or in common so this is this is really
really really really really important ok
you don't have a word per product you
have a word for your company you have a
word for yourself it's a value that you
then bring to everything that you sell
ok so at my company I have almost 40
different products that i sell i call
them azucar guides on top of that I have
the webinars and I sell partnerships and
sponsorships and I do workshops with
people and I do speaking engagements I
don't have I don't have one word for
each one of them they're all part of
believe right and so that's what you
need to do for your company your company
has to stand for something your company
have to has to have a soul all the
people who come in to your business have
to believe in the same thing so it's not
on a product level because the product
doesn't have a soul right you can you
can name your product something right
you can brand is something you the name
of your product can be one word if you
want to that's powerful it's easy and
short to remember but the overall
feeling that you want to get comes from
your business and comes from the people
inside the business believing in that
one word so that's really important this
is not on a product level this is
company-wide poor rob is it better to
use one's personal social media to
connect if the company is a new startup
how do you eventually transfer the
engagement to start up social media
platform so I believe it's a lot easier
to connect with a person than it is to
connect with a company and if you're
going to have a company based social
media platform and this works if you're
not building personal brand right you
start off in the beginning am i building
a personal brand or am i building a
company brand or am I trying to do both
so if you're starting up a new company
you know through the leader you have you
on twitter account do you want to be
seen as a thought leader do you want to
be seen
the expert you want people asking you
questions you want to create this
Twitter account for yourself or not you
know if you don't and you just want to
be the company that started through the
company I like having a face for the
company though so for example on your
Twitter account if it's a if it's a
company-wide Twitter account then you
know on the page you show the people who
are tweeting from it and you show at the
end of it you know who it was if you
just be their initials if you're doing
YouTube videos right show the people in
your company if you're doing Facebook
post show the people in your company
because people want to connect with
people they want to see who's behind the
brand who's pushing this message out
that's really important so if you know
you're going to go to a a brand then
just start with that start with your
brand if you don't want to build a
personal brand and don't worry about it
to start on the business side build that
up but again make it personal because
people don't want to interact with a
logo they want to attract with a real
person so it was prob thank you next one
is Camille my facebook page was doing
well we're getting 2500 organic likes a
day and now suddenly likes have fallen
by ninety percent over the over the past
five years can't figure out the reason
why so the two things to think about
Facebook the reason why your engagement
is probably dropped off one there's a
lot more competition than there was five
years ago a lot everybody's jumping on
the facebook it's super hard now to
stand out because if you look at
somebody's facebook feed right it's all
the stories that come up from from all
the pages that they've liked and all of
their friends now there's so many more
brands coming online so many more brands
having Facebook pages that it's getting
super competitive so you're not showing
up as much facebook in the past year has
also updated their algorithm where fan
pages are not showing up as much as your
friends so in your own you probably
notice on your own feet the pages that
you're that you like that you're a fan
of their stuff doesn't show up in your
newsfeed as much as your friend stuff
unless you're regularly engaging in it
so that's why it's way more competitive
than it was five years ago and
Facebook's algorithm is penalizing
branded pages instead of
your friends the way around it is you
need to get people engaging with your
stuff if people are liking sharing
commenting on your stuff then it's more
likely to show up on their feet that's
how it works so if somebody comments on
one of your posts then tomorrow when you
post again it's probably going to show
up in their feet if they ignore you for
five days then you're going to be out of
their feed unless they go back to your
page and type it in which they usually
don't so the challenge now is on you
providing quality information that
people want to engage with not just
here's something to learn but that
people want to like share and comment
because when they're doing that when
that quality levels there then they're
going to see it in the news feed
constantly they're going to refer their
friends to it their friends are going to
see that they're engaging with it
they're going to sign up so it's really
a big challenge now quality is more
important than ever to stand out on
Facebook so thanks to the question next
is from Millie what if we what if we
also have an oil distribution and I
masala brand distribution as well run
individual campaigns for each your
thoughts on how a taxi business can
benefit from social media ok so you lots
of different businesses here I would
think about the audience is if your
audience is the same then run it under
one campaign if your audience is
different than one another too so I
don't know how connected that what do
you have oil distribution and masala
brand distribution if they're the same
customers then I would run under the
same campaign if they're not then you
can have two different ones but this
costs and time and pain associated with
each one right I think any business can
benefit from social media campaign so a
taxi company you think about a taxi
company men taxi companies talk about
like the most competitive business to be
in is got to be taxi companies there's
no loyalty to taxi right it's whoever
comes is closest to you you flag down
that's you get to come on there's no
feeling attached to any taxi company now
there's one company here in Toronto I
don't know how internationally are
called halo which has an app where you
can you can book a taxi you can
and see you know how far away they are
from you you can see them on the GPS I
so that's that's a cool branded loyalty
play to halo but again the individual
taxi you had to make people care and you
can write if you were the taxi company
so give me a one-word right what's the
one worth your taxi company if you were
taxi company that that that you know
loved entrepreneurs I love entrepreneurs
I would want I would wait an extra ten
minutes right for a taxi that's what the
quick taxi company right if you were if
you adopted my friends Louise word of
being delighted that was you and I knew
I get an amazing experience every time I
book your taxi then I would wait or I'll
call that number right or I would ask
for this specific person but there's no
it's a commodity right that's a problem
you got to break out of the commodity
for again making people feel something
because if you don't there's no
connection to your brain it's a sec
you're sharing on social socks and I'm
not sharing it I don't feel anything
looking at it then I'm just going to go
with whoever is the closest taxi company
whoever is going to be cheapest right at
somebody undercut see about two percent
I'm gonna go somebody else but when you
have a brand when you have equity built
up with that by making people feel
strong feelings towards your company
then they're less likely to leave they
have loyalty and you can start that
campaign again on social again same
strategies you pick your one word you
share things are important to you you
share things that are meaningful to you
you should people that get people
thinking and saying wow I like this
company who are they going to call the
next I'm gonna taxi you got what is the
future of social media this comes from
an eel ah make me make predictions I
think it's going to be it's going to be
harder and harder and harder for people
to stand out and have success with
social because it's getting more
competitive it's getting more and more
come for every single day there's more
people coming online every single day
there's more companies promoting is more
people promoting and you only have one
you look at facebook you only have one
feed right how do you keep track of all
of that it's really going to be a case
where quality is going to rise to the
top and too many people this is a
problem too many people treat social
like advertising right you're used to
advertising campaigns used to pay per
click campaigns used to you know if I
spent a thousand bucks I'm gonna get X
number of clicks that's going to be why
number of conversions and it's going to
lead to this number of dollars right
that's an advertising model I can see
does that work yes or no if yeah then i
can increase my budget you can think
that everything is going to increase
down the line right Mike convergence
sales everything was social it's not
just a matter of pumping dollars into it
to get a return right i I've gotten
great returns I'm off my social I've
gotten even this webinar came from
social I got speaking engagements client
deals product sales new people want to
join my team lots of stuff comes from my
social channels but I can't say if I
spend five more hours a week or if I
launched two more YouTube videos this
month that it's going to generate why
and I don't know which ones lead to that
result but I know that it generates
results right when I went to Malaysia
and they paid for my trip and hotel and
airfare and speaking fee and all that
and I asked how'd you find me like oh we
saw your YouTube videos and we wanted
you to come on you said we have to have
you here so there's definitely an roi
but it's not directly measurable you
can't pull a lever like you do with
advertising and I think too many people
are coming from the advertising world
and are treating social like advertising
and they're going to fail the people who
have that mindset they've already failed
they're not going to have success and so
more and more people as it gets more
competitive are going to feel the crunch
not get our oh I see that this is feel
like it's not working for them and it's
going to be a greater and greater push
towards quality towards picking your one
word towards creating content that has
feeling that's the future and last one
comes from life
FIFA lelisa there's a few 01 part 1 part
so is can social media activity be
outsourced I am NOT this is a great
question and I am NOT a big fan of
outsourcing outsourcing your social
media the reason is the reason why
people share your stuff because is
because it has soul right this whole
talk about having one word create
something that means something standing
for something important there's a soul
to it you can't outsource ole you need
to have somebody a lot of times it
should be the person in charge the
person leading this campaign doesn't
have to do all the day and day out but
if you're the entrepreneur you got at
least spend some time on it because you
are the soul of the company you need
people on your team who passionately but
passionately believe in what you're
doing those guys are gonna be the ones
who can share your story best think
about so you look at look at a big
company right you look at Nike you look
at Nike what do they stand for that be
athletics right they love I thought
everything is about athletics you look
at their branding you look at their
their campaigns look at their soul she
look at their everything it's never
about hey here's why our shoes are great
we have the best you know technology and
our air souls and whatever they never
talk about that what do you see you see
great athletes doing great things they
support athletics so imagine them
outsourcing to a company that didn't
understand athletics right it wouldn't
work the campaign's wouldn't take off
you have to have people who live and
breathe and sweat this stuff love this
stuff and that's super difficult to find
outsourcing I believe your social
campaigns should be the sole of your
company and should be run by somebody
within your comfort so I think that's it
thank you for all the extra questions
you guys got a bonus 25 minutes that we
could get in on the webinar itself I
really enjoyed the talk seeing you guys
I don't know if we're going to again
we'll stay tuned I really enjoyed all
the talks and the interaction a lot of
you followed up on twitter if you guys
you know the full webinar I'll include
it in the link below so you guys can
check that out so for those are you
watching you've no idea what I'm talking
about you can watch the webinar below
thank you so much of your other
questions leave it in the comments on a
video response and i'll see you soon
belize